hey are you hanging meat in here it's
one of the Huskies what are the Huskies
and that sled doing dude why do they do
this to it it's so [ __ ] cold it
literally feels you know that scene in
Goodfellas on that then they hang the
yeah we're in a Matt Fraser what a meat
freezer you know what dude chin might be
chin might why is that door locked
hiss why am i dizzy I'm dizzy - what'd
you put in my drink dude he's gonna gas
it and then he's gonna freeze us and
then it's gonna eat us eat us what part
of the but if you first of all you
probably want to eat Brennan more than
me because he's good younger meat right
fresher it's not as to have any diseases
yeah and also here's me yeah I wouldn't
eat psoriasis me and you want to eat my
dick like it was eel besides his dick
what part would you eat first survival
situation yeah sure whatever you want to
call it I survive I mean Tuesday
afternoon yeah Tuesday at noon when
you're horny and hungry if we crashed in
a plane and there's just no lot of food
and he passed away just like that movie
and we agreed on it maybe or he or he
was like I can't I got and you're like
pinned under all this machinery when you
come here in that mouth and nose how'd
you do Tim I probably go for thighs
right thighs it'd be a good one
they say most the meats in your glutes
yeah that's just now you have to work
out in the dark meat of my [ __ ] I'm
not doing that you gonna survive or not
bro you're hilarious that that's what
you would eat there is no question what
I would honey get your stupid cheat I
would why they'd be rubber this was we
soft absolutely man what's the cheeto
porch II know you're my chin tried make
me that cream BBQ the two T's are stupid
old 51 year old cheese no you were
disgusting goddess not deep-fry your old
fat nose I don't know it isn't old fat
nose if they're locked so try it tastes
like you don't believe no it'd be a
calamari bro ah I would take the two
strips that go up your back that that
support your spine that stuff meat
that's that that's also where to eat
while
on a deer that's plain tax right that's
links that's not flying saying let's
flank no well my flanks bro no thanks
not a human that's plate
I believe that's your that your flag bro
that's the back that's the back back
steak right nice brochure like is your
ass no bro you made it cause you ain't
the where the flank steak is booty my
flank
I don't tough that meat is and win just
but I were there's no fat got it I cut
it into like jerky like round round
dollar round large pancake size yeah see
there's the flank the bottom you
couldn't be more wrong we were so all I
be eating the sirloin and the well I
have the Tenderloin that's right it's
the Tenderloin ah yeah that I be eating
is the Tenderloin and that's a beautiful
thing [ __ ] round brown snakes around
socks round sucks
every time I have top round which is the
cow's ass it's it's so tough brisket I
didn't know the brisket was down there
yeah me neither
Chuck's Chuck stuff sucks ass - Chuck
sucks ass beef ribs suck as well I agree
what point I never had white meat flank
shank shank bottom sirloin how do you
start on this you're weird dude anyone
you're the one I'm say it's gold so she
wants to eat ass dude oh yeah it's
freezing
hey this reason here ass we can murders
I was at a pumpkin patch I'm still in
chin it's normal if you're there with a
kid there's grown men there by
themselves it's problem right cuz
they're there they're trolling for
kiddies in my something's going down are
you doing my kid hip huzzah I rest my
kid has soccer
um carnival and his parents and kids
everywhere and then I just see a giant
like an oblong man just a big giant
oblong human being just boom boom with a
head nothing fit on his body he was in
me he looked like a kid at putting
together from like a Lego set in Santa
Monica at 3 p.m. because there's me know
your proportion this guy had this weird
and he was walking around alone look in
the fan swivel swivel head and his head
was on a swivel just looking at all the
kids you know like there are [ __ ]
candy yeah and I walked up and I went
hey bro
and he goes what I go you want to take a
walk or do you want me to make you take
a walk and then he go wow like you're
lying no and then he goes you I guess
you're gonna have to make me take a walk
and I go you don't want this dude and he
goes I do and he was really big and then
you suck him off look at kids it's a
free country I go not around here and he
goes then I go get out of here and he
goes wait you're Bryan Callen from the
Goldbergs aren't you I was like I am
thank you so much now we became friends
that make sense
yeah you make sense do you recognize me
um what'd you do this weekend dude I
spent a lot of time with my kids because
now my children at the age where they
have things like I don't know Cub Scouts
Girl Scouts so you don't feel bad do you
I sure do I sure do see mom putting a
lot of her time when the kids were
little and now it's daddy's turn because
the kids want daddy there but kid you
have to go the kids - my dad never went
to Cub Scouts with me they just drop me
off bro I was there and we had a we had
you know you're with a bunch of dads
then you had the Cub Scout leader who
wears a grown man who's in the same suit
as the kid he went he died his and he's
every bit of 50 man or he's an Eagle
Scout
you referred him as the there were some
there and I you called me Eagle uh-huh
have a stupid uniform on and there you
would think they're Green Berets the way
they strut around the rest of the kids
well you know I'll Brian you know I can
tie knots [ __ ] that's about it you know
Albright I was I was doing things like
guys guys gotta realize is this where we
take a blood oath sir no Jim that what's
in the manual you know just like oaths
and stuff and I go cool because I wanna
know how to tie knots and I'm at one
point where they were just talking there
was a pause and I went friends for life
guys and I threw my face the boy scout
yeah I didn't really know it I like I
like Girl Scouts do they offer you
delicious cookies
yeah Boy Scouts offer you know well
these are Cub Scouts now boys all
[ __ ] you know I'm saying
well it's look it's it's about
teaching them I guess all the time not
had a camp and be a good citizen how to
be a good citizen yeah it's called being
a good father you know I'm saying like
you don't yeah you tie them up yeah only
another dude dressing up the same as the
kids tell my kid out tight not to be its
next weird vibe I lasted one week in
mind but this is [ __ ] I don't care
correct I was a wee blow which is there
between Cub Scout and Boy Scout and I
carved a decoy duck it was the first
thing I ever worked really hard at a
decoy duck you know what a decoy duck is
yeah I do yeah and it took me it took me
six years it felt like thanks forever
and the guy looked at me and I was the
only one who stuck it out and actually
worked on it and the guy put up on the
back he goes give a unique gift to have
you guys proud to have you on my den and
I remember thinking myself I'm in his
den I went no I remember thinking myself
I like that feeling
I definitely working it something
because I didn't give you [ __ ] about the
duck but somehow I felt like I had to
finish that was pressured into it I was
like but he shook my hand said Brad hey
right angle that felt good so maybe I
did something right didn't even know
what I did that's I remember that I I
cause the last thing you follow through
on and though and I never went back and
I never went back you duck didn't look
like that though pretty damn close but
no you're right
you had some [ __ ] man you know I
think it's good
depends rate depends on the kid yeah for
me with some [ __ ] well for you is
probably you know I mean a lot of kids
have sports and then maybe the kids that
don't have sports off my dad taught me
how to tie [ __ ] not so there's that
yeah you know yeah but you got a camp
did that joke oh you gotta find
different animals check you got to find
different leaves from trees check okay
you missed Papa's job didn't know he'd
make it up here I think if you like
you're dissing I I feel like you're
dissing an American tradition God is it
going away too and it I don't know is it
yeah I think it the the ratings aren't
declined a little bit there are they the
signups I mean I don't know
is the Big Brother little the Boy Scouts
America how's that sign up looking for
me I know that they changed it to where
they're not gonna call it Boy Scouts or
Girl Scouts it just Scouts of America
change that annoys me what's wrong with
calling it Boy Scouts and neuroses if it
helps people to know what's wrong with
having it just boys and just girls I
know so it's not changing oh they're not
changing
yeah they shouldn't why should they
is that discriminatory if you call it
Boy Scouts or Girl Scouts those Girl
Scouts make a fine [ __ ] cookie man
yeah when did when they'll strike back
up it's not on the holidays I don't know
but I had to buy a shitload of them last
year
I loved tag-along and those Samoas and
The Thin Mint yeah you could Starbucks
has some [ __ ] fake thing that's
going around January in April look
forward to that yeah I like the ones
with the chocolate crunchy cookie and
the mint in the middle coated in
chocolate Thin Mint you [ __ ]
terrorist
I don't know come on bro you're the one
dissing her Boy Scouts and now you have
Girl Scouts it's amazing out of your
Scouts you're you're an expert on the
cookies that the Girl Scouts but you're
dissing the Boy Scouts the Boy Scouts
not offer any harm maize slides groan
Jack Jack Jack then I like get the
cookies wrong you're like you call me a
terrorist ah there you go the thin Moors
Thin Mints about did you say Thin Mints
Thin Mints breast I like I like the thin
mints the tag-along is amazing never mad
at the shortbreads those Dodos are
[ __ ] lemonade's [ __ ] Savannah
Smiles [ __ ] you you put down some
cookies huh I haven't in a while but I
want to I'll tell you I did for Sunday
my cheat meal I went to the old Julian a
takeaway order myself a whole Paul
Madero not cheese pizza slide for the
family just pop a sob here's some real
Pete the best pizza in the world the
best did he say that he lied he gave it
up no he's like that's good it bothers
me when people don't give it up for
Jelena Pizza Mike and my kid won't eat
pizza right he will eat that pizza is
the best you'll eat I've eaten pizza
okay I mean
in Italy I've eaten pizza in New York
I've eaten pizza in Chicago no we're
back hates everyone only closes
artichoke pizza New York julene is the
best I've ever had
Larry artichoke pizza New York I had
pizza in Naples this where my friend
said you have to come to the pizza here
in Naples and so we went upstairs in
this little place and he was from Naples
and I have to say it was ridiculously
good
Julian a bet pizzas hard to her too
[ __ ] up how do you spell Jelena GJ
yeah Doug i na you spell with it but
Jelena J I didn't achieve Oh Travis
laddies a genius but G there's Gelinas
to see Julia take away it's the third
link done I think Jim it's right next to
that there it is even but it's literally
right next door being should go on there
and get a slice of pizza you don't have
to wait yeah I'm starving now you are
great sandwiches great turkey mmm better
nice to eat there pretty much every time
we do a park on all the time I've been
there a while heaven dude we're gonna
sugar fish for a hot minute nothing
wrong sir fish either I mean they're not
giving that fish away though they're
really not it's not a cheap lunches now
no there's certain restaurant lean is
the way to go yeah yeah there's certain
restaurants you can spend hundred and
twenty-five dollars for on two people so
quickly Julie that uh Korean barbecue
this weekend chin not this weekend what
what happened I was actually working a
lot on videos on your videos not just
mine but also the nine the scenes it's
gonna be finished I mean this is a
behind the scenes come out [ __ ] seven
years six months I come out they you
know no a scenes for for everything even
your show your comedy special recording
behind it's a lot of work that's a lot
editing yeah it's six hours so I got it
down down our fifty I might just release
it like that you think there's a special
person watching a like 50 but these
episodes already like an hour and a half
two hours anyways true I think people
will dig it you get upload to the fine
kid page for sure yeah they're used to
long-form and then I come up with a
shorter one two for the regular folk you
do that how much of it
is of me shadowboxing and doing push-ups
there's a good amount of you doing
exercises for sure good good yeah good
that's important and then chin launched
his own channel called burger pizza
burger piece I just did a video pizza
burger pizza burger yeah so I made a
break to pieces of people huh and that's
this bun it's the fast [ __ ] I've ever
heard no [ __ ] used to be thrown under
pants chin did you take two cheese pizza
slices and makes that his bun for
burgers that sound good
yeah it's crispy on the outside and it's
like chewy on the inside of the bun or
than pizza by now or you could just put
hamburger on your pizza but I hear you
it's good man not my fatigue skin a cat
yeah yeah we low-energy
this Monday I feel like nothing hello
you got nothing uh like nothing happened
like you asked me what I did this
weekend I didn't ever have anything
we'll ask you did I can't remember a
goddamn thing
well that's because all my friends are
gone oh you're not around gotta be with
the family never see Rogen yeah and then
I'm with the kids oh you know so that's
what happens mmm I mean yeah it's not
like it's not like nowadays what are you
gonna do you gonna go out to dinner it's
not like you ever we that we went to
this party woman ray like you know no I
mean I can't go and I'm self-conscious
at 50 to go I wouldn't go to a club no
let me get a table you would acknowledge
it's tough to give me to even go out
like I like you know like Drake's in
town I just when I'm at I just want to
go home I just want to go home man yeah
I work all day and then I leave town
Thursday to Utah yeah I'll be home one
of my fights is getting old dude getting
old took my Papa Papa job to box and
burn I didn't I do those cardio classes
to the dad do the car class he sure
walked in so I went [ __ ] this noise all
right you just did something that I
can't do no interest in I don't like any
kind of a class like that
same here jogging spin you know see
people in groups jogging or biking it's
just
no snot for me I'm a team stuff has
always been like I you know in corporate
retreats where they do these trust
exercises where you fall into each
others arms I guess it's good for
cohesion but I remember I've never
forgotten college I was thrown a
basketball against a wall in my dorm
miserable it's [ __ ] DC in this dorm
Lima the [ __ ] am i and these guys
combined a he's kind of kind of slick
looking dudes they had like one guy had
a Rolex on when he had kind of you know
quaffed well well quaffed like if if if
I found that they both had got their
nails done I wouldn't have been
surprised they looked very shiny shook
my angers you knew huh I got ya
and he goes want you pledged for us for
sure
you look like you'd like to pledge I was
like nope I don't
you don't think where the meeting is I
cannot go so yeah because I would watch
them I don't know if you had this I'm
sure you have this in your college but
you'd watch these pledges and they'd
have to do crazy [ __ ] when they get
drunk and they'd be like brothers for
life no frat well but when you're
probably the football team that's kind
of like your own Club you're probably
friends yeah yeah you're in a different
let's all look together right around we
only hung out each other and party it's
a sort of a fraternity yeah not as
douchey but it is bonding when you play
football
right cuz but I see yeah I like doing
the classes more excited private
training forever
it's the classes are good cuz any other
people in there to push it you know yeah
competitive yeah you don't want that in
the end they're tough they're fun taking
what classes I like was the ones that on
it
our classes are [ __ ] good all the
time actually that looks fun when you
and Aubrey and your brother would just
doing those Sprint's or whatever those
are what are they called the circuits
circuits at for me yeah but that box I'm
wearing it's like that but it's it's
like you do mitts so you get one-on-one
mitts
then you go to the bags then you go to
the blacktop and there's like weights
there and then go to the turf and then
the sprints I like it man and I mean
there's surprised some of those like
young girls are can go
[ __ ] ever there's like a big dude out
of she looked at shape he's a little
beast though
yeah there's mitts it's a good class man
you know that's really good I like this
stuff mm-hmm because the personal chandu
it for so long it gets boring man and
can't really you can't really [ __ ]
your way through those classes like
you're moving man yeah next thing it
goes myself it's so like chaotic but
tell you like Dan that's an hour and bam
thousand calories burn like [ __ ] yeah I
was at glove works these pro football
players came in Samoan guys they were
linemen or something and they were just
they were so [ __ ] wide it was so
weird like what if you whatever you
think is why they were wider and they
were did we weren't really lifting they
were just doing all kinds of weird like
body stuff like you know you know stuff
I guess to keep themselves a balanced
yeah movement and stuff like that but
like just they look like giant human
fists little iguanas yeah like there's
no points anywhere it's just blunt
everywhere being dudes do yeah
their job currently playing for the Rams
I don't know who they played for I just
know they both played you know pro
football one of them was a big-time like
made it I think he was right you know
signed some huge contract well you look
at him you go well of course
how would you fit into a [ __ ] car
there's a guy who works on this
unschooled and he couldn't get into my
to move my Tesla he couldn't get in he
couldn't really fit palsy well he's he's
woozy
six-four and he's I swear to god he's
not fat he's 295 pounds but he's so wide
yeah he goes yeah I'm just too wily
skinny he tried to get any cuz I can't
get in man he goes okay cuz you come
over here and a Hawaiian dude is huge -
got it but he was just I go how how Mike
what do you Angus about - 95 and it's
not even yeah and he does not really
figures you don't look fat he goes I'm
not fat I'm not I'm just a giant Viking
Jesus yeah he's so wide so [ __ ] wide
it was this thing your shoulders are
just like not like a you know it he
looked like the like the letter H like
if you took the letter H and filled it
huh that's all those twins were
Oh remember the twin that on it those
big thick twins Oh oh yeah those are
your boys those are big boys
yeah are those guys in Denver bigger
than people here what guys like your
your football players when you're in
high school uh what do you mean bigger
so the reason I mention it the reason I
bring it up is because when I remember
going from high school to college I
thought I saw big people before right
like in football players when I first
did college I was like oh my god these
people are freaking they're here yeah
they're not from this world there's a
giant I did stand-up at Mizzou yeah
Mizzou and the football team was there
and the same thing well you're you're
yeah you're 340 pounds go let's get some
of the big high schools in California
really it's a blow your [ __ ] mind how
big they're they're huge
it's so weird it's like what are you
doing sucking on a cow how'd you get
that big how about I was at the Grove
yesterday and I mean I don't know if you
guys I could not I mean I know it's plug
to say I could not not stare at this but
oh they have this halo ice-cream there
where one scoop is 60 calories no sugar
it's delicious called halo ice cream so
I'm being ice cream I'm there my
family's there and we're tiger we're all
sitting around eating ice cream and then
there's like a little like part like
small park you're next and there's this
mom they're hot hot mom yeah with the
biggest titty out feeding her yeah but
I'll just try out I'm you know how most
important ever nope just this impossible
to that hot and the hottest [ __ ] this
babies suck on you guys you know like oh
wow that's a big fat Danny my mom and I
didn't wanna look creepy cuz y'all see
fiendish son it's you know themed I was
like this just like yeah man that's
crazy and then I probably something like
still doing it huh and I was going back
and forth like goddamn typewriter like
okay titties still out there we go and
then but no no one in my family one to
dress it and if I saw big titties
sticking out anyone I don't see the big
t my dad goes excuse me I go yeah but
that was the first thing in their mouth
look at it
he's not did you see the girl with a big
titty hanging out there am i yes
I'm excuse me a woman had her breast out
and went well not after explain it sound
creepy there was a brute it was awkward
I had a knack I'm talking like
impossibly fat - I had an acting teacher
who went who looked it she said this
just like that yeah but she was playing
at him like squirting in his mouth here
I had an acting teacher is that normal
like is that cool to do a new thing now
I think it should be but I don't that's
the person I in the in the words of my
acting teacher in the worst of my acting
teacher yeah I think it's sexy sometimes
I mean oh wow
no I mean man my hack Musa got a woman
Peter job I think it's sexy and
everybody was like alright he goes oh my
the only one I was like you know it's
it's it's it can be just hit her it just
catches you like as in like oh damn
she's hot he's got a huge tit out you as
a baby that was the first thing in your
mouth so it's excusable if you are
intrigued by it well you just don't see
today yeah but here's the thing if she
was a warlock what I'd like come oh my
god damn girl she's beautiful you're
like you know but that's normal that's
like you know you it'sit's you're just
feminine is again you've been at a
friend's house and a three-year-old
comes and sucks on her titty I see you
she like for you off you're seeing like
four or five-year-old suckling it's like
yeah have a acquaintance that a close
friend but they still the mom breast
feeds the kids and literally you'll be a
milk conversation like Dan that's crazy
all really boom well a lot of countries
when their food was scarce that would
that was very common yeah with John 18
rights and when I Erica yeah I don't
know I mean I don't really have that big
of a problem with it do you know the
baby
artistic yeah it's artistic that baby's
[ __ ] cute I'm bombing bad either she's
not
very pretty it's not
she has dreads yeah it's some big-ass
titties filled with whole milk there you
go that's right
well anyway maybe that's a big-ass feet
Brenda they're into lactating moms I'm
just saying it caught me up I just hit
reminding me that some just this
impossible very a pity
very natural and I I didn't like that no
one acknowledged it we all saw it like
it come on man yeah see this mom with
the fat to the gang unit see I would
have noticed a force and I would have
been escorted out great and possibly big
titty or some chrome engine yeah already
huh about some big I thought your cars
spitballing all right what's up dude you
know yeah um I was shooting today
shooting was very early and I did the
Goldbergs and then when I'm done with
this podcast I going to schooled what
time do you shoot that till probably
till very late
knowing my schedule right now Wow but
and I hope for how many week well how
many weeks do the Goldbergs and I go
until I go until January and I've done
for seven months
but you see of October November December
January that's right oh wow I'm in it
I'm in it well we're both pretty busy
right it's just the way it is you know
yeah but um the problem is that when you
do a TV show you're there all day but I
got stand up to start doing starting in
February so I kind of got a write new
stuff and is it weird that I can't come
up with one joke I have what's called a
writer's block right now well yeah I
feel you gotta go get onstage but while
you're I've been doing I mean I just do
now or lots but you know yeah well I
actually never I don't need to perform
as much I usually get my writing done
but I got to start
have you tried that technique where when
you're about to fall asleep you hold
something in your hand and then as soon
as your does off you drop that thing
that's in your hand and which
up and these are writing right at them
now I don't do that I just said I set a
timer and just start writing or I walk
or you know or I'm always I'm enjoying
the car and I don't where would you
write if your unsaid all day you don't
and then you got to worry about you're
in every scene so you gotta be you'll be
present - you know it's like you're not
writing on set no I'm not reading you're
not writing on said you're there it's my
dusty yeah
good problems to have but it's you know
but then yeah but then when you said
you're done January then we can start
then it's not like no-one's like you
have to rush to create a new hour
exactly exactly
you summon stress on yourself they don't
need to know correct
I'd be fine I have like a lot of time
yeah podcast and right you know wait
till you're done it's gonna be fine
right tell me everybody it's gonna be
awesome so I said my mom she always like
home what else have can i right now it's
my third special on out now what do I
have anything else is any updates with
the special no no yep okay um y-you
heard some gin like well I thought I
heard yeah yeah it sound like she gonna
have hears in my life so it's underway
I'm sure it'll be fine
that's always a strange thing I don't
know best I can do like how do you
control do my best I think it is I think
an awesome and I think it's coming
together really well
but least there's more places than ever
to know is there well I'm saying more
than ever yeah but where let's say let's
say this is your 1997 your comic you're
not with HBO Showtime comedy salmon
Tommy central like there's no YouTube to
blast so there's no there's no Hulu
Amazon DIRECTV YouTube bread Netflix I
feel like the only place people watch
comedy specials is Netflix and Showtime
though am I wrong as far as what what
would move the needle you know you can
do want you don't want you and be honest
what move the needle the most probably
is YouTube really that it's gonna give
you the most eyeballs possible hmm now
what I hear about well well yes and no
any joke
[ __ ] Dick and Harry can upload us
anything they want YouTube yeah so then
quality and the fans might think oh [ __ ]
me it's fun you to be is nowhere else to
go right no so there's a little bit of a
negative connotation with it yeah but
for the most can you put the whole log
on or would you put like put the whole
thing I'll put the whole thing on there
I'm saying Fred if you want the most
views possible and to make sure everyone
has access to it see you have to have a
you have to have a you have to have a
subscription or membership to Netflix
Yeah right
Yeah right some people that's what I'd
like to do I'd like to I would like to
just I just want as many people but
here's the thing be if you just side
this conversation I Showtime if you just
release it on YouTube these days it
looks like yeah I know I know
never don't give up TJ Miller yeah it's
great you know I'm saying but you look
at guys like what's-his-name released
the [ __ ] he does the hot pocket take
he's all Jim Gaffigan so he released it
on like YouTube read on all the paywall
yes Amazon yes DIRECTV so it's been it
sound really well for me cuz I'm working
the same company and it's it's been
really good for him it's Jim Gaffigan
though it's Jim Gaffigan Jim Gaffigan
like Kevin Hart could do that Jim
Gaffigan is a mom I'm a monster louis
c.k used to do his own thing there you
go no bleep yeah well I mean look man um
yeah there's but you got to get out
right yeah you have to get it I'm
waiting I'm waiting hopefully show time
you know are they done with the editing
wise no yeah color Greg did this letter
be done with editing color they just got
done yeah yeah no it's been dog 0:06 you
know it took a while editing took a
while you know you know Rogen edited
zone Sarah I'm good girl I was there cuz
you know I know what oh yeah you know
and you gotta lose [ __ ] and there's a
lot of like there's a lot of stuff
in the middle of it it's just it's just
the way it is you getting editing is the
very important let me see the trailer on
this gin you actually take out stuff
yeah I thought you just changed me 58
minutes well remember Brian did an hour
and a half yeah yeah which I don't know
you got it's gotta be down to 58 minutes
got it on my ad blocker I'd blocker
broke again so we'll watch a commercial
some how these people who [ __ ] tell
you go company this last 40,000 views
[Applause]
I love Jim oh my god he's a piece Lois
discovered my wife had a brain tumor I'm
not even making this up it was removed
she's great everything's good the stage
looks cool scary we have five children
and there were moments when I was like
oh my gosh if anything happens to my
wife those five kids are gonna be put up
for adoption
did some shows in China you visit some
places you think all right there's a
language barrier but I so [ __ ] funny
he makes a he'll have you in champion
theaters look at that he put it
everywhere yeah that's what comedy
dynamics does you eat either that or you
do a Showtime or a netflix thing so you
know cool interesting but that was in
commie dynamics right sure was nice for
lesson a room is that is that a is that
an off-white light I call me name right
down there is actually a great company
it's just a crude of whether or not you
can whether your name is big enough to
get people to go there
hmm so yeah be real kind it that is
actually why is that
oh is that brick over there now that's
that real privately my I think it might
be imported brick I'm not doing the same
thing was a massacre brought what I was
saying is that so all I have to do is
just get my name out there and then just
get it on all the platforms and then
that's that's another idea that you can
do with your special if say a netflix or
showtime passes on it so does that work
last time
yeah is that now is that horse or your
old zebra now I'll see alive how's that
work Jim his body in the back it's
probably back so anyway so what I what I
just need to do is get it out there on
any platform and I think that's a great
way to sell it and I think that at the
end of the day
Showtime Netflix these things are not
that important now have you worn those
gold shoes have that
they look small for your feet yeah
there's a lot of moving pieces yeah sure
a lot of moving pieces that's my
favorite that's oh I don't know it's a
lot of moving pieces
here's the thing Brian lot of moving
pieces hey we're out with Netflix mm and
Showtime mmm so here's the with that you
know yeah a lot of moving pieces right
we're just waiting on a few guys who
will enjoy the guys have they actually
gotten it they know in this business you
don't know anything no you just have to
go with what the person on the phone
says you know and you know you look the
bestest when you get offstage or you did
a big project or a special like what you
think your agent goes gyah fun oh my god
scuse me sir yes have fun
that's all it counts whatever wherever
the chips live mint Tim no [ __ ] now
were they live that's why you're here
yeah I I'm glad I came
I'm glad I came to this whoo that bad
did you have fun
I've gotten so good at knowing when
something's not gonna happen it's a
subtle thing I've become a master at
because this town is all lies
it's the bet it's it's dude it's funny
this is the best script I've read in a
long time we do well we have a lot of
different options that we're gonna go
out with and there are a lot of
difference so right now what we're doing
is grouping up to see where we can push
sometimes when they when they bring an
idea agents um and then when you go
through all the steps like the embassy
stages of that project just like you
know the guys that created Will and
Grace they're the best because they're
so nice to actors and max and Dave and
make it one time I I audition and he
goes okay I know do you want me to do it
some other way and he goes no now here's
why I really think you're great I think
you're wonderful and I've known you a
long time and but I'm not gonna tell you
I'm not gonna be Hollywood with you I'm
gonna tell you just not right for this
part it's great I'm also max goes deer
hair like this if you ever thought about
just cutting that off
Michael what do you mean he's just I
don't know keeping all my shave it looks
so awesome I was like I will I think you
shave my hand she did it was great
those guys to the test they they love
actors like they are they get them they
get it yeah I would get it you know it's
like the do you see the the grind of
always being in the room hey how you
doing another pilot season that's back
in the days that's all gone now it's so
different so funny
yeah and what would happen in Hollywood
I said we had what was called pilot
season when what the network's would buy
them by the pilot then you would the
idea then you would write it and then
they would green light the pilot and
then you would go into casting and that
would be in the fall and you'd really
have like two months and if you don't
get a job in those two months or see you
next year that season
yeah you'll be doing an episodic but
you're not gonna be getting serious yeah
and it was and then you you test I was
like eh oh yeah they don't do that
anymore of a pilot since there's not so
many really as much it's just so many
different islands even though sort of
yeah there's so many different shows all
the time with on then it's hard to you
know yeah so it's not the same as it
used to be I have an audition it's so
long well partially because I've been
lucky enough to be you can't though
right yeah what would you a dish before
and that's I've been lucky in that sense
but any kind of contract early yeah yeah
yeah thank God thank God you know it's
it so how can you imagine if you're
sitting here playing you know where your
specials gonna go you know acting games
I'm a [ __ ] bubble in it yeah that's
the norm but for a lot of people I know
Will Sasso one time said we're talking
about the business and and we had both
tested for something that we didn't get
and he said well the business is in in
five years we will look over in an
audition room and the guy from Modern
Family whoever it might be will be
sitting across from us auditioning it's
just the way it is I've seen it's what's
also interesting is that you have a
really hot run I'm including movies and
you just don't work again yeah but
that's but that's with anything right
like besides if you just
not to come but if you just want to do a
regular nine-to-five job which is
nothing wrong with that we're same thing
day in day out you know just doing the
same thing over and over there's no you
know there's no performance basis hours
you're gonna know that shit's gonna be
poppin but not letting the same wait
exactly just know that if you go into
thinking that's the reason less 1%
people do it that's right there's a
reason for that you know my mother's
tell me a story about how I'm she knew
this really wonderful Persian family the
Iranian family and they'd come over from
Iran and they put their the they worked
so hard in lots of jobs and they they
put their whole family savings their
fortune into this amazing Iranian
restaurant and it was in it was in like
this incredible building and they got
this amazing contract and she he was he
was an amazing master cook or something
and and she was actually I'm sorry and
he was businessman and everything and
they put everything into it and they had
their grand opening and it got a lot of
it got a lot of fanfare because there
wasn't an Iranian restaurant in New York
City it was like a big deal and that
weekend as they were opening the Iran
hostage crisis happened oh no and it was
the end no one to run no one did no one
went to the OPA it was just done Iranian
food is amazing by the way
damn but it was the it was like their
whole life just went away no one went to
that restaurant in fact people were
outside saying protesting yeah and they
were like but we're not even there I
think they were about hi they weren't
even like oh this is a risk right yeah
everything right you want to open a
restaurant good luck you want to be an
actor coach Immy an athlete good luck
please but don't you know it is what it
is but at least a lot a lot of sports
and restaurants off these that's just
bad luck you you're right and you're
investing yourself you know you can
control the narrative a little bit and
sport some sports somewhat also but but
I think you should also have an outlook
where you know that the it's going to
end in some way and that the people that
are succeed are able to
mold into another thing like just use it
as an opportunity to go somewhere else
stay open stay malleable stay flexible
become a businessman you do whatever it
is you have to do but that's that's kind
of how I look at this career like what
are you gonna do just act now I'll do a
podcast I'll do stand-up I'll do you
know you're writing you're doing all
those things the people that that I
think are gonna be in trouble are the
ones who are strictly just actors that's
that's a tough gig it's just it's cuz
you're dependent on so many other people
saying they signed up for though you
know one of the gigs also yeah how about
uh this weekend speaking of going to
things up my Wow basically all the guys
who played college football at
university Colorado were here in town so
they're playing us see so many Tech's
dude we're here meetup was there just
can't do it didn't do it and then the
college team in 2003 that I played on
ranked number one in the nation number
two for the longest they unducted to the
Hall of Fame and all of them flew in or
like dude come on we're doing this I had
no desire no desire I asked my dad like
you something wrong with me I just have
no desire to doing these stuff like I
don't think so because I think it sounds
like we're going to go back room
reminisce yeah that's what days and I
just have no desire to do it yeah drinks
and then talking about that yeah I'm I
said I also don't like the castrato
you know I'm saying like what do you
been doing and you got a you know rego
over everything you stuff you already
know and [ __ ] family and I think
about seeing friends I don't think about
reminiscing I just think about laughing
like I like to laugh so if I'm not gonna
laugh I definitely don't want to
reminisce no I really don't and also if
I care not trust me I'd reach out to you
yeah [ __ ] up a little is it trust me
out but find would you hold on as Bruce
it sounds it comes down to what do you
actually like to do well I like I like
friends and I'd treasure those times as
good time stuff like that but I'm just
yeah I much rather be with my son
Ramez with you guys yes yeah and that's
[ __ ] up like some wrong he's like 'no
i don't think so
well that's what happens as your kids
get to like when you start to
communicate hang out you would just wait
other hang out with them on a weekend
even at that carnival saw soccer
carnival and stuff you know it's it is
that it is what it is but watching the
kids have fun it's like you become a
parent it's a different kind of thing
this foods making me so hungry to me
have you ever been to uh god I forget
the [ __ ] name of it in Glendale free
does know as a Persian food yeah
no but I've had Persian food my
favorites when people though this person
feels good is it
you mean the Persian Empire you mean you
mean a country that's gone back I don't
know over five thousand years did they
figure out how to make food and make
amazing food amazing
alright Jan woody guy gave me some
current events over an events before he
dies all right how about we check out
cats will do this together I haven't
seen this but a cross-country Runner
becomes Nikes first professional athlete
with cerebral palsy that's interesting
good for them this is the commercial
here yeah oh wow you might say look at
him go
does he run for eunice tree Oregon I
wish I knew Danny can run the
cross-country runner an Oregon broke
down tears when he surprised when the
news that became the first professional
Nike athlete in history with three Wow
it's 20
damn this actual video them tell him
he's an athlete just about to receive a
professional athlete contract from Nike
I became the first freshman athlete Nike
history palsy this is actual video of
him Gintama that's pretty crazy
he thought they were just filming him
finishing this run they surprised him
with the Nike contract just to know
inside John's folders a Nike contract
John is the insights direct of Nike
[Music]
[Applause]
so cool that's really cool
it says tatters that let's guy worked
for Nike Brian yeah that's crazy that is
cool
now is he get a few mil off this
contract Dan that poor kid yeah scroll
down to what else is there it's super
heavy damn that's cool man there you go
my friends and family too you got my
back story through everything this is
frickin dream come true proud to
officially be part of the swoosh family
there's this tendency other thing that
people sarva palsy cuz they don't you
know they have trouble speaking a lot of
times that they that their brains are
not that their brains are similar to the
way they're moving in but they're
they're completely lucid they they have
zero mental handicap at home zero it's
all physical it's all I'm a muscular you
know you could what did uh Ethan Hawke
in theft or not you thought he had a
piece even that's alter but even his
brain was a hundred percent yes his body
that's where you're there your muscles
just stop work Eric's disease that's
cool man with a sketch in let's check it
out I remember this guy the fire
festival founder remember he was excused
promising this amazing getaway oh yeah
all these crazy artists and everything
else but it turned out to be crap I
don't remember this yeah he had all
these famous people and it turned out to
be a complete disaster so it says there
so music bash in the Bahamas oh yeah
never they had like styrofoam like food
like carriers they had like sandwiches
is supposed to be like luxurious foods
it was all [ __ ] and he'd say like
gianna and a bunch of those people are
gonna be there yes let me give him six
years yeah he's a serial frost there's
my first one
defrauding investors of twenty six
million dollars Wow the [ __ ] of these
fingers I didn't get away with it yeah a
lot of guys like this the motivation
here was greed desire to have a flashy
lifestyle alright yeah
six years she had guy said once he gets
out I'm sure he'll be right back on to
the next gams just what he does huh he
takes years he'll be on DuBose next game
as soon as he gets out what else get
chin Jesus great people Bachelor Vietnam
I think I remember cat kind of mentioned
this before so they went there to find
love and then two girls ended up finding
love it's supposed to be the girl and a
guy oh that so too like they all want to
go find a dude yeah but two of the
contestants who are girls found each
other
found each other dan that's cool so you
want to see them make the confession
here hell yes
today wait is this a lesbian bachelor no
no oh here we go
yeah no hopefully they're saying it's
not you it's someone else that she's in
love with and that's her
I think this is scripted but I like it I
believe you Selleck come home with ya
she's an actress too about to be do they
celebrate this in I don't know how they
are there I imagine I'll be just like
most Asian countries though yeah
superscripted good for them though smell
this a mile away she's all actors
gobbled it up I don't you sir confirm
the two women are now together and in a
relationship
mm-hmm all right let's see this together
to Lana Del Rey and Azealia Banks he did
what Elia banks that's her on the left
that's Lana Del Rey right here okay
that's azealia banks and they're in a
Twitter feud over Kanye West
let's check this what's the problem I'm
imagining that Cecilia banks Wow okay
Lana this would be cute if you were
consistent with your outrage and refused
to collab with ASAP Rocky who is
physically assaulted women - to me this
looks like the typical white woman
taking using a weakened target to
pretend to be an ally I guess she's
supposed to be working with Kanye then
okay keep scrolling down or it's Lana
coming to this I mean that's just it
makes you the enemy like a separate
graph kick grandmum in the face icons to
move because they paid their money to
see their Idol a moment of silent Jesus
reached out touched him because he
didn't have a great security tonight you
want white feelin looser still all right
I don't know enough about this yeah you
do where's Lana
it's a promise not a threat
sending my surgeons number and I could
suck guys I know la Banque she could
have been the greatest female rapper lie
but you blew it
don't take it out on the only person who
had your back were they friends I won't
like not [ __ ] you the [ __ ] out period
you know that addi pull up in time say
it to my face but if I were you I
wouldn't gangster Christ [ __ ] peep I
wrestle this [ __ ] around to this
thing say that cuz I'm bored with okay
we don't know enough about it captain to
probably knew it she supposed to be
organic last me catch me outside
that girl's a book killing there now
catch me outside girl what else you get
alright this did you guys know that
people use airdrop to send lewd pictures
to other people strangers no you know
you could do that right just do blue can
I have my ear drop on them you know I
always have a dog never why would you
always have it on you but remember Tommy
no no it just shows your phone your name
on your phone but why would you always
have it on no like out in public I
always have it on because I'm always
dropping stuff here like I randomly
going around showing just dropping his
dick
I'd like to your hilarious thank you
tweet - sound now there's a guy was
jerking off in the back on yogurt
samplers and handing them out some
people just want to get theirs in you
yes a little different that's called
digital rape it's a little different uh
but when you walk outside here chin
you'll have your drop I do you just
leave it is more convenient I well but I
guess the easiest way to fix this is
just to have have it connected to only
your contacts you can just set that up
in the setting yeah no [ __ ] but you have
to like I know if you work on like
production you always have to have it on
for everything yeah but not when you
leave the business
no I mean even if I'm outside and I meet
someone I turn my phone off or not turn
this option off oh well driving no no I
it'd be hard to send me a date because I
my job so I know you're you really know
how to turn yours on I guess I hear I
got a setting friend him I'll just set
it up I needed my phone what else you
got this
Aaron Hernandez I don't know if you
mentioned this before but did you hear
that he was sexually molested as a child
I did yeah yeah so I guess the Boston
Globe did a report on it and one of his
buddies mentioned it and his brother
mentioned that he was sexually assaulted
sexually molested and there's rumors -
right he had a little bit of a boyfriend
a boyfriend on the side
Johnson said that Aaron disclosed later
in his adult life that he had been
section listed as a young boy Johnson
Cline to say anymore the globe out is
one of Aaron's lawyers Nicola George let
us say smoking to him sick showpieces
child all right Aaron sexual complexity
was one of his closest secrets when he
hinted at only really high school
correct friend was yeah the time might
have been yeah anyway the dick tastes
interesting I didn't hold on
Sansui said he finally came out in his
late 20s to family and friends after
Hernandez suicide despite difficulty in
doing so he believes that Aaron would be
proud of him for his past relationship
hey I'm sure Wow hmm interesting stuff
so so this was his boyfriend when he was
like high school yes not a boyfriend bro
okay what would you call it
what do you mean boyfriend yeah the
boyfriend yes I saying it's just yeah
it's boyfriend you had a chicken side
football catching catching [ __ ]
catching freaking out routes and banging
dick hi everybody
that's all I grew up in a [ __ ]
troubled childhood men yeah yeah hmm and
there's that thing to people say right
that when you're molested as a kid
sometimes that affects for sure xual
orientation yeah yeah all right well
and so the story thickens yeah well not
really we kind of knew this yeah I think
Brennan mentioned it before but I mean
they actually put it out here on the
Boston Globe yeah for this story make
sense end up for sure when I get out of
here what I'll read that well you know
yeah this was in Florida
I'll just play the video it's a
Lamborghini that crashed into a truck in
front of it took off and jumped in the
car next to him and he they bounced
check this out some grant the father and
then do anything to that truck witnesses
so there's a driver and passenger in the
sports car watch as they moved to the
sidewalk behind the black Mercedes
appearing to avoid the man they just
rear-ended watch as they then jump let
me hop in the Mercedes and bounce that
was really crazy I mean a Lamborghini is
like a 300,000 not a car how can you
just leave it there that looks like they
were going shopping damn I'm not mad at
her I'm mad at all the driver in the
pickup she black do you see her button
her legs
I find our farms II don't know why I
like athletic women and kills doesn't
notice look at her she's in chef eight
if she was all white we'd go math and
Athleta sure she's in shape
she's I can see what her ass looks like
from the front she could see that shelf
I don't think you've ever playing sports
cuz I'm not fully gay but I hear you
Brian well I I mean I don't wish she had
a [ __ ] and hanging up the front no I
don't see her but I do see a rump and
and just a very well-put-together body
she's very attractive yeah and I like
his black t-shirt too I mean I like her
I mean I like her yeah maybe they rented
that thing and jumped out the back ah
yeah a follow-up on this chin I mean son
Doug so they haven't caught him yet it
feels like they were like that that'd be
a good way to shoot somebody waiting to
get out and there's something a Rob his
truck I don't know that's weird I mean
they just left the $300 not weird like
you're gonna obviously be caught by
alright but they still have minimal to
catch them either guy and the guy that
they hit was a firefighter who took
picture of their car on the that their
car imagine not because they can't track
it yeah yeah so I was like a rental or
test drive no that's so [ __ ] weird
yeah well let's see what happens
throughout the week Ford to that what
else you got
get the investigators alright if that is
a bizarre thing right that's very baby
Brian yeah it is yeah how do you explain
that they know that looks like they
purple they didn't purposely do that
they don't own the car their friends are
behind them they ran to that they both
stopped they went [ __ ] this down their
friend's car and sped away
yeah but why they ran over to the
sidewalk very very abruptly like watch
watch okay why not just go inside to the
mercedes-benz right away that would take
a second yellow light right that cops
there's a red light so he just rammed
into them probably texting and then goes
oh [ __ ] gets out the truck driver gets
out so there's a driver and passenger
the sports caster gets out of the car
Lamborghini he's ready somebody's
grabbing papers something in there
they're just chilling right they're both
like what the [ __ ]
farmer say goes kill the [ __ ] and
then they're out that was them going
freaking out going what the [ __ ] should
we doing so on that Mercedes let's get
the [ __ ] out of here they stop like oh
is he the guy grabbed his head like this
yeah so who's a rental car prop yeah
like dude you just crashed a [ __ ]
Lamborghini I think Brendan's the guy in
the Mercedes went holy [ __ ] let's get
out of here yeah they jumped in the car
can't wait the real take now real
segways this time people I was gonna say
that's the best part that is real take
she's good good gorgeous yes
what else you got gymnast alright so I'm
sure you guys have seen this already
this parkour robot from Boston Dynamics
yes insane so first check it out it's
pretty cool right jumping over a big old
vlog does all this and just even look
real to me it looks fake huh
thing light on its feet in it that's
what makes it look slow slow down it
makes it look more realistic anyhow
apparently that took 20 different takes
people thought it was just like a smooth
go from the back foot it took him 20
times do that yeah yeah Daniil it so
it's not like it's not dialed in and
high percent yeah yeah shows
capabilities when it does get down and
you're looking at this stuff doesn't
scare me saving some lives man you're
gonna be that's who you're gonna be
fighting against yeah that's good robots
uh-huh they have to have like a crazy
battery pack cuz it seems like it'll
just go away they'll figure that on
don't know I'm sayin we'll make electric
cars and [ __ ] sure don't figure that out
no problem
I saw the so late yeah you know me I'm
not big enough your cars but there's
this new things called bill injure bill
and juror bill and tin I'm sorry follow
them on Instagram now but it's a $60,000
electric truck I'd buy this thing
it's it I think they start taking
reservations in 2019 there it is three
pound Bollinger b1v I'm put it down
deposit on it
oh I love the way it looks doesn't look
cool it's 60 grand 60 grand
not bad no juice box you free great
that's what I want bro that side that's
cool
I want the military vibe I think sick me
and my dog me I'm a shepherd me and my
by trained Shepherd and that's my love
that I love I don't drop to John 20 but
they start taking reservations I think
co19 the ball and whole enjoy what is
that some electric car company Wow
that's their first model house sick
looking I'm gonna wait till the reviews
come in that's a great-looking car I
know great looking car Wow first truck
and you down the middle like you the
middle opens up so you put wood all the
way through really cool looking yeah I
love cars I would me to like build
houses I build houses and I built fires
and that way if I'm in the like in the
wilderness I like that another thing
sweet yes so your Bronco what kind of a
charge does it get probably
it's just 200 miles yeah that means a
hundred miles so that's good for me
though because I don't drive him that
much around she need a second car yeah I
really like sweet I like to try you see
the truck one farm bottom-left option
yeah oh yeah like the truck one more
than should be hmm don't come out that I
think 2020 very cool look so boxy you
like g-wagen so chin
I don't there you go no you think this
interior is kind of like but I like that
Spartan interior yeah I want the because
I'm just gonna use it to [ __ ] each my
son sports stuff okay yeah wipe my
cheeto fingers in the seeds yep I'm
gonna use it first man a puddle [ __ ]
and you know I mean yeah dude rope in
there would I like these types of trucks
I like something like that that's pretty
cool that's uh yeah um
now do you only watch WWF when you drive
the thing I have that work gender don't
they like box those don't make sense to
get rid of this that doesn't make sense
dude that's so cool that's that's it we
can do with that in LA monster truck
just try things a monster yeah I don't
we don't need that what else you got
dude this did you see this play no Jeff
Jadeveon Clowney and Chris Ivory grab
his tread grab his dread so check this
out yeah oh so he tackled them with that
dread and I looked it up that's legal
yeah I was so crazy that's illegal
there you go what it's a legal play yep
yeah see you if you're gonna have dreads
you know that that's a possibility part
of like we have guys with long hair
people grab it yeah out of the uniform
holy [ __ ] crazy no idea cuz what you
gonna say you can't touch the button but
but he got it first you got a 15 yard
penalty for it right now that's barstool
sports clowning around oh Jesus seems
very dangerous to me so let's go ahead
and cut yeah yeah yeah yeah tuck it into
your [ __ ] oh I didn't know dreads
hung on that I thought can you tuck
those dreads into that helmet is there
no [ __ ] now
how would you do with him be I don't
know you're right he'd put him up in a
bun for extra padding on the back here
goddamn head hmm
ow that's funny though [ __ ] get over
here
yeah yeah did you guys ever have long
hair no my hair doesn't grow them up and
breaks off my hair yeah you ever see
like a shrub you know shrubs grow up and
not down do you have like Hershey rub
man how long really long wherever I was
in a heavy metal oh wow petia pictures
that I'll find some there Stan would you
just do this - no I did like a headband
yeah Wow all that stuff yeah little scab
dude um sad news Ariana Grande and Pete
Davidson spoke up he'll the splitsville
yeah they're rushing into it weren't
they they said that the Mac Miller thing
was the thing that took it over the edge
her emotions and everything when he died
she sedate him yeah
she was super close to him and they
broke up because of his you know he just
wasn't sober ever and then they
separated she got with Pete and then
when Mac died then asked to have their
problems I loved Pete I don't know her
at all Pete's great though yeah that
sucks they were engaged and stuff I know
I want to work out but of course it's
not working out what else all right
does he get the $200,000 ring back 100k
what do you do what do girls do with
that if it's an engagement and she all
seems so rich Trey gives it back right
we can he get money back on it you don't
get your money back when we be worth
more now yeah oh she wore it what you
can sell black market for sure yeah
that's true 100k son that's actually
yeah
I mean there are plenty of yeah
whoever's a fan especially for her ring
yeah you buying that yeah I would
imagine money begets money what else
yeah dude got one more Joe Rogan leads
top comedians social media ranking for
the first time B they beat out Kevin
Hart yeah okay the hearts number two
beat up [ __ ] Kevin Hart the other
ones I was surprised though I figured be
like all the top top comedians but you
know Michael Blackson
and sarah silverman out bill mercy huge
not I don't Jessica Robin more I don't
know her DJ Hugh the other yeah I didn't
know he was still popular I didn't know
he's still alive I'm not being mean
Tommy Chong I also didn't know he was
alive is that true yeah he's weird
yeah in other words they're the most
what does that this mean they Instagram
Twitter all that stuff if you're being
talked about if you have most like song
and all that kind of such a pothead so
maybe it's like he's guy he's got a cult
figure
you know he's Cheech and Chong man so
then like that other girl she's youtuber
big you can't had a Netflix show yeah
she's not comedian but okay Kathy
Griffin okay and then there's Kevin Hart
number two number one number one that's
cool man scored a four point four
million Instagram favorites
you know the rocked [ __ ] tweet about
a special all right
pretty cool that was a good one chin
that it dude that's it dude tie my nose
is freezing brain well Brennan I think
we were to call it a day then because I
don't want you to be cold I really don't
I do not want you to couple cold boys
dude yeah it's been cold it's been
called couple cold ease uh I think
that's it dude uh it is buddy you want
to go get some sugar fish enough time
sugar fish we'll figure it out this is
where we leave you chin yeah I love you
a couple days free guys just announced
my Showtime County special tickets just
one on sale January 19th in San Diego
Spreckels theater two shows on Saturday
one at seven one at ten get tickets now
to fake a calm and this Thursday Friday
Saturday Salt Lake City Utah I'm coming
wise guys eighteen through twenty that's
this week get them now after that's cob
San Francisco Sacramento New York that's
all November get them get them
Utah see you Thursday Friday
tik-tok on this the fired kid growl